It takes a lot more than accurately re-creating
a comic book character's outfit on the big
screen to make a superhero movie worth seeing.
And anyone who's seen the terrible film version
of Captain America from 1990 knows it.
In terms of comic book costume accuracy, it's
a ten out of ten!
For having literally everything else be absolutely
terrible, it's a negative twelve-and-a-half.
Needless to say, when former Marvel Studios
head of visual development Charlie Wen sat
down to adapt the classic Marvel Comics cosmic
super team the Guardians of the Galaxy, he
had a lot more on his mind than comic book
accuracy.
To get the right look for the right character,
Wen and his team tried beginning with the
right words before anything else, which informed
the design process.
"Oftentimes if I'm designing, or if I'm working
with other designers that are in my department
at the time, it's starting with those descriptors,
and more in that, what do those descriptors
remind you of?
And so there's just a lot of adjectives, actions,
verbs, anything that define who those characters
are, that I wanna make sure that we always
go back to that."
So what process did Wen take with these relatively
obscure Marvel D-listers to bring them into
the mainstream?
Here's what the Guardians of the Galaxy almost
looked like.
Because the Guardians of the Galaxy were relatively
unknown characters before the movie broke
out big in 2014, Wen had a lot of freedom
to explore different designs for the film's
characters and settings.
Part of that freedom, said Wen, came from
Marvel Studios chief Kevin Feige :
"Kevin is a true Star Wars fan."
“I think it was something like 20 something
times or in the theater, maybe 40.
I don't remember, but he loves Star Wars.”
That, and the fact that the Guardians themselves
were pretty obscure in the public consciousness,
meant that Wen was free to create Marvel's
very own Star Wars.
"This one also had a special place in my heart..."
"If you go with Iron Man, Thor, Captain America,
Hulk.
All these characters are pretty defined.
People know what they are and Guardians, nobody
knew what Guardians was.
It's very niche.
What was great was it also left it so that
we could do a lot with it.
If you upset some of the hardcore fans, maybe
it's okay because there's not as many of them.
But what it did do is it allowed for a lot
of exploration to create a Marvel Space Odyssey."
In 1976, writer Bill Mantlo wrote a spacefaring
comic book story called "The Sword in the
Star," introducing a new character drawn by
Keith Giffen: Rocky Raccoon - like the Beatles
song - not Rocket Raccoon - because they didn’t
think they’d get sued for that?
Anyway...
. Armed with a gun, a cigar, and a bunch of
attitude, Rocky came back six years later
with a new design as Rocket Raccoon when Mantlo
was writing The Incredible Hulk.
The character would come back again and again
over the years, never really straying from
the core characteristics Mantlo had given
him at the start.
These attributes played a huge role in Wen's
design work for Rocket.
He explained the important details he wanted
to capture when designing Rocket:
"He's impatient, he's got the little guy syndrome,
the Napoleon syndrome.
Definitely a big man in a little body, big
character in a little body, bursting out at
the seams.
He's always up to eleven."
When you look at the concept art Wen created
during Guardians of the Galaxy's pre-production,
Rocket's huge personality comes through clearly.
Even the way he's standing — battle-ready,
with a snarl on his face is perfectly contrasted
with Groot's presence in the background.
And while we're on the subject of Groot…
Unlike Rocket, Groot evolved significantly
from his comics debut.
In 1960, on the cover of Tales to Astonish
#13, a giant tree monster named "Groot from
Planet X" shows up on a busy city street on
Earth, daring someone to fight him.
He returned as a monster 11 years later to
fight the Hulk, and finally started resembling
our peaceful, heroic Groot when he appeared
in 2006's Nick Fury's Howling Commandos and
2007's Annihilation Conquest.
In the latter series, he seemed to develop
the friendship with Rocket Raccoon that became
so central to the 2014 film.
In fact, according to Wen, Groot and Rocket
were two of the biggest question marks going
into the film's pre-production period.
"Nobody knew if this was gonna work, and everybody
was very nervous about Groot and Rocket, because
the whole movie was contingent upon those
two characters, a tree and a raccoon, especially
being an integral part of that five character
team."
Meanwhile, Wen contrasted this moss-topped
Groot with Rocket's fiery personality.
When asked about the words he'd use to describe
the ideas he was trying to get across with
his early designs, Wen said:
"The background tree, when he needs to be,
but he's a nice, quiet, empathetic, sympathetic
addition to that group.
The quiet stream that keeps a peace between
all of them."
Star-Lord has had plenty of looks over the
years, though a lot of them have kept one
constant.
From his first appearance way back in 1976
and up through his more modern adventures
in Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy team in
2007, Star-Lord seems to like wearing some
pretty weird headgear.
Wen tried to capture this element in his concept
art.
But the design presented some headaches.
"A very German World War 2 military, the shape
of the helmet.
Even the way the pants are.
A lot of those, we certainly can't really
go for something that ... Even the color,
the blues, we can't go for something that's
gonna hearken back to World War II Nazi uniforms.
It works with Hydra, for Captain America,
Hydra, Red Skull, that makes sense, and they're
villains."
The design work took a positive turn once
writer-director James Gunn came on board.
Once James came in, the retro kick-back with
the music, with all that, was very specific
to James.
He knew really the tone and feel he wanted
them to feel like, and so that was really
important.
Oftentimes, we don't always get that, and
so James was much more specific with saying,
'Peter Quill's gonna have a tape deck that's
important to him.'
So I'm like, 'Great, that makes our job so
much easier already.'
Because that is a visual cue.”
That's what led to the cinematic look — the
facemask and exposed hair.
But the design communicated more about the
character than you might have realized.
"Having his hair be exposed, in a way it's
... Some people were thinking, 'How much does
that actually do to the character?
You're only showing the hair.'
I'm like, 'Well, but hair actually shows character.'
If it's unkempt and all over, you already
see a part of that character."
Nova was another important character from
Marvel Comics' batch of cosmic stories in
the 1970s, though the version we got in Guardians
of the Galaxy didn't quite resemble the Earth-based
superhero Rich Ryder who went by that name.
We didn't have the super hero Nova, as opposed
to the Nova Corps."
But just because Nova as a lone superhero
wasn't written into the script at the time
didn't mean he wouldn't make an appearance
in some fashion.
As part of his explorations of Marvel's characters
and designs, Wen created some Nova concept
art that was inspired by Ryder's superheroic
alter ego to make sure the filmmakers had
as many options as possible.
"I knew at the time, I was like, 'Okay, well,
we're probably not gonna be having Nova as
the lone character.'
At least, it wasn't written in.
I was playing on that line, just in case.
So I did some takes where it's more heroic,
it stands out more, right?
As, 'I'm a significant character that needs
to stand out.'"
But while Wen's superheroic version Nova didn't
make it into the film, it's still pretty exciting
to know that his loss was John C. Reilly's
gain.
"Hey!
If it isn't Star-Prince!"
"It's Star-Lord."
"Oh, sorry, Lord."
We did tons of takes, and I ended up doing
this one that's more like the military space
police, because that's what he serves.
So really, ultimately, it just needs to serve
the story."
“He's got a codename!”
“It’s an outlaw name.”
“Relax pal.
It’s cool to have a codename.
It’s not weird."
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more exclusive Looper videos with
Charlie Wen about the creation of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.